哪怕今天说爱你，
他欢迎你，
他特别强烈的希望你来，
这是他真实的想法，
如果有一天他的工作没有那么顺利，
他也有很多的压力，
他可能对你就没有那么的好脾气，
没有那么多的好脸色，
那两个人的感情就是会变。
我现在是遇到一个人生抉择的问题，
所以想来听听龙飞姐和大家的意见，
是关于要不要辞职去美国读书的问题，
我现在呢已经收到了还不错的大学的录取通知书，
过几个月就开学了，
所以这个决定还比较迫在眉睫。
那关于为什么要去美国读书呢？
是因为我男朋友在美国工作，
我们要结婚了，
结束异地，
那现在呢是三个方案，
第一个是我辞职去美国读书找工作，
第二个呢是他辞职回国找工作，
第三个方案是继续保持异地的状态，
今年是30岁，
在一线城市，
我是国内普通的本科毕业的，
但是因为运气比较好，
又比较擅长面试，
就进入了大公司工作，
现在年薪是40万，
福利好，
工作环境好，
同事的素质也都比较高，
整体来说还是比较舒心体面的。
男朋友呢是比较学霸，
他是国内名校的本科毕业的，
之后又去美国读研究生，
毕业之后工作呢，
在美国，
现在换算成人民币大概是年薪百万，
也是在大公司，
我们双方呢都是有。
我兄弟姐内的，
我爸是做生意的，
我妈是体制内的，
家庭整体经济还是比较宽裕的，
那我从小也是比较受宠，
父母呢是知识分子，
付出型人格，
我刚毕业呢，
就在国内帮我买车买房托举我，
他们思想也比较开放，
所以不干涉我出国或者是回国的这个选择。
我男朋友呢，
他家境比较普通，
家庭关系也比较复杂，
经济上呢，
之后应该需要我们的扶持，
目前我是倾向于让他回国，
但是他呢是倾向于让我出国，
我们也是遇到事情都会互相商量，
想去的。
原因呢，
第一个就是从纯粹的感性的个人角度，
觉得去留学，
去美国生活可能是新的人生体验，
感受多元的文化，
就有一个说法是把人生当游乐场，
也不用考虑太多，
那可能当我80岁老了的时候，
会觉得这段经历是有意思的，
他以后会有遗憾，
第二个原因是我的工作长期来看其实不算稳定，
没有上升空间，
可能年纪大的时候会被裁员，
但是我觉得我的履历在国内再找工作应该也是不难的，
第三个呢是可能相比于国内，
美国不减，
有可能我会找到工作，
或者是创业成功，
或者是做自媒体成功，
好的，
这种可能性的诱惑比较大吧，
然后我男朋友呢，
他觉得美国工作和创业的天花板比较高，
想继续奋斗到大富大贵吧，
他觉得现在国。
那经济不好可能比较浅，
现在回国他觉得在美国也没有奋斗出来什么，
就有点遗憾。
另外一个原因是可能过几年我们生小孩想生在美国，
因为美国的教育体系可能比国内的应试教育会更好一些。
另外呢，
就是我男朋友回国找工作的话，
肯定会降薪，
他大致算了一下，
他回国之后，
我们两个人收入的存款可能跟他一个人在美国工作年度的存款可能是一样的，
他说这种情况下我辞职就不要有压力，
就可以去探索创业，
或者是就干脆享受生活。
如果是不去的原因呢，
我们也分析了几点，
第一个就是我经常听龙飞解说，
不要为任何人何任何事放弃自己的工作，
可能我从心理上其实也是不敢放弃，
现在这个收入高，
待遇好，
又比较有光环的工作的，
尤其是现在其实很多留学生或者比我能力强的名校的人，
其实都想来这家公司，
我觉得我来既然已经在这里了，
就是要心里有点数，
别飘了，
那除了工作呢，
就是想着怎么去玩儿，
就是去美国的话，
就要读书找工作，
按照我的性格，
在美国肯定也是闲不住，
要去找各种赚钱的方式，
就觉得非常非常的累。
第3点呢，
是美国现在政策不好，
其实我们外国人找工作是很难的，
工作肯定是会降级的，
可能我就要偷下这个孔明己的长衫去做小生意啊，
或者去小公司工作等等。
我怕到时候这个心理上落差很大，
因为毕业之后一直被这个大公司保护，
然后家庭堡也是教的比较知书达礼吧，
我怕遇到外面那些乱七八糟的人的应对能力会很差，
就有点秀才遇上兵的感觉。
另外呢，
就是我去美国之后，
我的工作和收入不确定性都非常高，
男朋友虽然现在说是工资全部上交，
可以签婚前协议去保障我的权益等等，
但我还是比较怕以后落入这个家庭主妇的俗套的剧情。
另外呢，
就是我父母年纪比较大了，
可能他们10年之后就要80岁了，
而且我们家庭关系很好，
我也担心他们老了以后照顾和陪伴不够，
大概我就是这个情况，
想听听龙妃姐的建议，
你本身很有条理，
表达能力也很强，
思考问题也已经很周全了，
其实啊，
我没有办法告诉你是去好还是留下来好，
但如果是我的话啊，
我本人从我自身的这个喜好出发的话，
我可能到30岁的年纪了，
我很难再去适应新的环境，
很难再去转换这个身份，
并且在同时还经营好一段感情，
因为经营一段感情它是需要土壤的，
这个土壤里面可能有，
比如说你自己每天心情好不好，
你自己每天健不健康，
你自己每天压力大不大，
就是两个人都是属于那种压力不是很大，
心情很好，
也没有太多。
和外界的因素干扰的情况下，
这两个人在这样的土壤下，
这个感情才会越来越弥合，
越来越紧密。
但凡是有一个人有牺牲感，
有一个人是处于那种压力特别大，
工作特别不顺心，
在外界又有一些其他元素的干扰的话，
那这个土壤对于两个人的感情必然会生出很多嫌隙、
埋怨、
牺牲感。
从我个人来说的话，
如果我是30岁了，
因为我已经到了一种适婚适育的年纪了，
可能我需要的是一种特别稳定的这样一个安全的一个环境，
让我去繁衍后代啊，
就是我自己说，
如果我到异国他乡，
我可能会带有一些更高的期待吧，
你看我都已经放弃了国内的工作，
我都已经放弃了我自己那么多朋友，
我来到你的城市了，
那你是不是应该对我各方面的关怀做到位，
前期的准备做到位，
甚至有可能在下飞机的那一刻，
如果他因为公司有事情没有来接我，
我可能就会心生怨念，
甚至于我到了他所出租的那个环境，
一看那个马桶很脏，
我也会心生怨念，
甚至于我一看他都没有为我洗好床单被套，
没有为我整理好枕头，
没有选我喜欢的被子，
我都会心生怨念。
我是说从我的角度来看待这个问题的话，
我也有这种感觉，
对，
我明知自己的性格是那样的，
那我就可以预判得到，
如果我。
牺牲了一个年入40万的工作，
牺牲了这么好的工作氛围，
这么好的同事关系，
这么多的朋友，
包括父母的陪伴，
我去到他那里了之后，
我一定会对他要求很高，
且心生怨念，
因为感情这个东西是会变的嘛，
哪怕他今天说爱你，
他欢迎你，
他特别强烈的希望你来，
这是他真实的想法。
如果有一天他的工作没有那么顺利，
他也有很多的压力，
他可能对你就没有那么的好脾气，
没有那么多的好脸色，
那两个人的感情就是会变。
是的，
这个我确实也考虑过，
然后我爸妈呢，
也是比较担心这一点，
他们觉得我去了之后心里压力太大，
可能会抑郁什么之类的，
就觉得还是我心理上的问题。
如果我现在决定不去的话，
我男朋友他现在工作确实还蛮好的，
他可以远程办公，
平时呢也不忙，
最近还在努力的升职加薪，
他说我不去的话，
他肯定是会愿意回来，
那我还是觉得有点愧疚，
就是有这种心理，
但是我想我辞职去他好像也没有什么愧疚感，
道德感太高了，
就不应该有这么高的道德感，
是吧？
对，
就是他的人生选择，
明白尊重他的人生选择，
但是我最后还想就跟你深聊一下啊，
就无论你做什么样的选择，
你从今天此时此刻开始，
必须要告诉我自己，
我做的一切的选择都是基于我自己，
基于我对我自。
给负责任，
基于我对我自己的判断，
我做出的这个选择，
千万不要说选了留在这里又觉得啊，
自己好像是失去了一个很好的机会，
拓展事业，
交新朋友，
失去了那样的机会，
千万不要有这样的想法，
另一方面就是如果你选择去跟他在一起的话，
就千万不要有牺牲感，
你不要觉得是我牺牲了国内的好事业，
国内的这些社会关系，
去那儿投奔你来了去，
那为了你去，
你就是为你自己，
因为你自己想拓展事野，
你自己想人生丰富，
你自己想看看你的能力边界在哪里，
你要冒着这样的心态，
才有可能两个人的关系才有可能经营的下去，
明白，
那如果说我们俩都找一个比较中和的方式，
就是这几年先暂时再继续异地结婚，
这种状态可行吗？
分人，
有的人呢，
他周末夫妻也罢，
异地结婚也罢，
他可能对于真切的那种拥抱，
和真切的大家一起牵手吃饭，
做很多事情，
他没有那么高的需求，
他所要的需求就是在精神上有一个值得我爱的人牵挂的人，
对于这样的人的话，
他异地夫妻，
他OK的，
嗯，
所以说这事儿的话，
分人，
看你自己，
你是属于那种说看到人家万家灯火的时候，
内心就开始沉下去了，
说为什么没有一个人在家里等我，
为什么我出门一把锁，
进门一盏灯，
总是我一个人，
你要属于这样的性格的话，
就不要谈异地恋，
明白。
我想最后问一下，
从感性的角度来讲，
像龙飞姐以及评论区大家年纪比较大一些的，
就是历尽千帆之后，
觉得这种把人生当游乐场去玩一玩，
体验一下多元的文化和这种不同的生活方式的，
你们会觉得这是比较珍贵的吗？
还是说从更加务实的角度来看，
还是去选择更务实的？
其实是看气质的，
就是说每一个人哦，
他有自己独特的那个气质，
那个气质不是我们单纯说哎，
这个穿着衣服好看的气质，
不是那个气质，
是心理学上的那种气质，
心理学上他的气质，
他有的人就是属于开拓性的，
他就是要求变，
就是要尝试各种新鲜的东西，
但有的人他的气质就是求稳性质的，
他恨不得一眼望到头，
平平淡淡的就是他所向往的好日子了，
所以这事儿真的就是分人，
同时也可能分年龄，
就不同的人到了一定的年龄，
他的想法不一样。
拿我自己来跟你举例子啊，
我年轻的时候就是比较爱折腾啊，
这也想去去，
那也想看看，
这也想试试，
那也想尝尝。
有了孩子了之后，
到了我40岁的时候，
我就变成了那种求稳，
就是别有什么大的波澜，
别有什么大的惊喜给我就是么，
平平淡凡一眼能望到头的日子，
我就觉得挺好了，
能平平安安的活着一辈子，
没有遇到战争，
没有遇到天灾，
没有遇到人祸，
没有遇到谋财害命。
有遇到恶性案件就很好了，
嗯嗯，
所以这事儿的话，
就是还是回到你自己的内心，
你分析你自己的性格和你自己的渴求明白了，
那我没有其他问题了，
希望你能过好啊，
就无论你怎么选，
你是选留在国内还是选去到那里，
都希望你能够自洽，
选了你头就是最好的选择，
就哪怕说这个男人跟我最终没有走到头也没有关系，
我其实是想找到的是那个最好的我自己，
就像我那天看那听那个瞿英姐他的那一个博客，
他说他从来不觉得他遇到渣男，
每一段恋爱的话，
他不是很在乎说这个对象怎么怎么样，
他在乎的是我在这段感情当中我成为什么样子了，
我喜不喜欢这段感情当中我自己，
那我套用一下他的这个观点，
其实特别适合你的这个现状，
你别管以后我跟他是不是能走到最后，
我跟他是不是能结婚，
能生孩子，
能修成正果，
能圆满不重要，
重要的是你，
你想要一个什么样的你，
好的，
好谢谢，
再心啊，
再见啊，
我确实不同的年纪啊，
感受真的不太一样，
年轻的时候，
二十几岁的时候都想试试啊，
到处都想试试，
我觉得我像个狗一样，
到处都想秀一秀，
到处都想撒泡尿，
到处都想站立一下，
就是我的领地，
就年轻的时候就是那种感觉，
你们有没有这种感受，
年纪大了就想法不一样，
年纪大了就是真的。
只要身体好，
没有复杂的人际关系，
没有人来内耗我，
没有人来影响我的情绪，
我每天都过一样的日子，
都可以看看剧，
看看书，
看看不同的人生故事，
看看不同的案例，
就是让我每天过一样的日子，
都可以，
就是这种感觉。
记得点赞关注哦。